hey y'all I'm Walter bene dziak - half
Italian stallion
I want you eating three eggs a cup of
flour some milk 2 cups of sugar and
crack me a birthday cake sounds good to
me
all right coach all right so we're
talking about Rocky 5 today
you're watching this or listening to
this we just did the fan scription
episode about Rocky 5 which is what if
Adonis Creed was in Rocky 5 what I did
was kind of bring a bunch of stuff from
the later movies in the series and
incorporate that into Rocky 5 to improve
it by the way for listening to this just
on the podcast make sure you subscribe
to us on iTunes and there's a video
version of this also on YouTube so if
you're watching this or listening to
this you could have multiple ways of
watching or listening so thank you guys
for tuning in in any case Rob I wanna
talk to you first about some of your
memories of Rocky 5 you said you saw
this the first time in like 91 right
yeah I didn't see it on the big screen
hmm
I had seen by that point I had a friend
who liked rocky so I'd seen the Rocky
movies by that point yeah I think it's
because my parents didn't give a crap
about the rocky films and since they
were the ones who were taking us to the
cinema because I would have been 10 in
1990 maybe maybe 11 um depending on when
I came out I just never saw it so I saw
with another friend on home video back
in the days when you could rent and it's
pretty boring yeah I mean I liked it so
here's the thing as a kid some kids
really respond well to the Rocky movie
some some kids own as a kid I liked
Rocky one enough and - but as a kid like
Rocky three and four were the ones like
in Rocky four in particular for sure
it's basically a card game yeah it's a
did we've had this discussion before so
as an adult I I think rocky one's the
best but so I saw it we were just kind
of like bored and I remember like kind
of half doing other things like we're
like playing with LEGOs are doing
something now what we were doing this oh
yeah guns it's like I think we're
reading you're like reading comics or
something and
yeah only half watching it so I didn't
see it again till Doug got in to the
Rocky movies not really hardcore but he
hadn't seen them really so he's like oh
watch this I think he was in high school
I was either a senior in high scores
like a freshman in college that was the
last time I saw it and my impression
didn't change much its I appreciated the
dramatic elements more cuz I was like an
adult yeah and so as somebody now who is
like growing up as a teenager I was like
oh he's like trying to connect with his
son and I get that as a kid that was
like kind of just over my head but I
still had just some of the same issues
where I'm like at this some pot this
movie that just bores me and they're
they're all deliberately paste which is
a critics codeword for boring with the
purpose or boring but good like cuz
Miyazaki films critic are deliberately
paced you know a lot of worsen well
zooms or did the Godfather I think it's
very deliberately paced but I love that
movie so I then have a problem in the
rocky 1 or 2 or any of the fourth isn't
deliberately pace that's actually for
three and four pretty quick but with
five yeah there's some about it just it
never grabbed me yeah no I think that's
with everybody I mean the general
consensus of everyone people still hate
Rocky 5 like hate it with a passion I
have a visceral hatred I was just yes no
you know I just did the Tamra's never
seen of rocky 4 with her because she has
never seen Rocky 4 before so we watched
to it three and four in a row and I
talked about it on there that you know I
like Rocky 5 but I'm not saying it's a
better movie oh do what you like but I
said I'd like that I'm saying it now Oh
God I like Rocky five better than rocky
4 oh you you enjoy the world of pain I
already know our world of pain I know
every day I'm in a world of pain anyways
alright but I mentioned it on there and
people are still just like oh I think
you haven't seen Rocky 5 you must have
not seen it you know I understand that
is the only logical explanation look the
the the odds here are high that I've
seen Rocky 5
much more than most people who are
watching this video or listening to this
yes cricket tourists those are the odds
right but you know I think that in the
grand scheme of things like we're
talking last time about rocky 4 with
Apollo's death which I wasn't a fan of
but it yielded great results with you
know with the Creed movies without Rocky
5 who wouldn't have gotten Rocky Balboa
and we probably wouldn't have gotten
Creed either there's a good chance we
would have gotten cuz if he had gone up
on top kind of in the right film I don't
think he would have returned right it's
kind of like the Rocky movies he's got
come back I know that's the whole thing
so like I know originally you know what
even when we're talking about returning
the Jedi how they're all these like
stories around how it was supposed to go
the same thing with Rocky v I mean John
avildsen returned to direct it would
erected the original Rocky movie and
Stallone wanted in the script for Rocky
to die at the end after that street
fight with Tommy Gunn you're supposed to
die like before the ambulance gets to
him or something like that there's like
a script page out there that you could
read just has like the whole breakdown
of what was supposed to happen and
apparently I will say this I think the
audience would have riot that's what I'm
saying and that's that happen and the
studio execs kind of knew that because
they their famous quote about this was
you know James Bond doesn't die Batman
doesn't die Rocky's not dying and they
made him change no it's gonna die what's
wrong with you and people have said
especially appleton and people who were
involved in the film it was this
downward slope and if you would have
died at the end it would have made sense
but yeah what it made sense but do you
want the most inspiring movie series of
all time to end on such a downing note
like he loses all his money he gets
brain damage gets beat up by his former
protege and they dies is that what you
would have wanted would that have made a
great like a really good installment of
the series I don't know yeah I'll say
this like even when I think about films
that have pulled a kind of light well
like last Jedi or something I'm like
there was like a redemptive quality to
him trying to save the day at the end
where I I'm just thinking like all of
that happening him it just Rocky dies I
know
right I mean what if there wouldn't be
much to grab on to sure exactly
I mean dramatically sure but there's
dramatic stuff in there anyway it's just
buried in all of this like really dated
stuff not as dated as Rocky for is but
there's a lot of weird 90s like rap or
with hip-hop like beats and randomly
thrown in there and it just does not fit
because bill Conti came back to score
the movie and all this stuff is covered
up by that I'm like why conquest know
that like come on man that drives me
nuts cuz Conti score is grave and that's
I well that was I think Brad Jones and I
were talking about this how there was
that weird transition from 80s to 90s
that happened in about 1989 1991 you can
see it in ghostbusters to where all the
rap got brought into the soundtrack you
can see it Adams family where they had
the Addams Family rap at the end of the
movie and you're like what every like
that was just in all of a sudden then
that lasted for a while it was only I
think at the end of the 90s Inc is
starting to die out again yeah but that
was definitely a part of a lot of
soundtracks and especially in this one
but when the score is not being
interrupted or when you know take you
back which is a great song from the
original one by Frank Stallone is not
being remixed into a weird thing
the score is really good there's a
really like I listen to the the
soundtrack law is writing this on
YouTube and stuff and there's some
really talked about that intro and yeah
that my god I love Ian I like that was
one of the memories I had from seeing it
as a kid as I remember loving that
opening credits sequence I was like I
was like so I get to the point that the
movie disappointed me history right and
you know I like the the war track that
Vin de Kola wrote for the the rocky for
fight the actual fighting but using
conquest which is the one they used in
like Rocky 2 & 3 and stuff it was
basically the the sequel to going the
distance that that song over the Drago
fight with new stuff added to its like
that makes it so much more epic just
hearing like there's no synth it's just
all like really powerful Orchestra told
us and it's just fantastic and just made
it made it feel like more serious it
just meant it feel like oh this this was
like this should have been the apex of
the Rocky movies and for a lot of people
it is but I think it's been instead of
these Star Trek 5
some about fifth films around that time
yeah I think that film came out right
around there but then you know they jump
right into the Rocky and the shower and
stuff and how he's got like you he's
going crazy basically from the brain
damage that he was known by Drago there
and he thinks that Adrian is Mickey and
like he's just completely out of sorts
that's another fantastic dramatic scene
I like as a kid I didn't like that when
I saw it when I was in high school you
see here oh yeah exactly when I saw it
when I had like gotten out of high
school like I enjoyed that a lot more so
that's something just between the two
times I had seen it that had change or
is like I like that a lot more as I
became an adult I'm just like aha
they're cops because when you're a do
you think you're invincible and I'm like
yeah right
it can't happen is an adult it was like
oh that guy's brain is jelly so I mean
it was a definitely a big shift from the
cartoon heights of rocky Florida trying
to drag it back down to what made it
work in the first place in the first two
movies yeah so like it is a big tonal
shift and I think people did
overcorrection like maybe they need to
find like a middle ground somewhere I
mean yeah it was a very dramatic drop
but I mean I enjoy that tone that's why
I like rocky the first two movies are
why I like rocky I don't like it because
of four you know I mean like I mean I
know that's a lot of people's favorite
in the series but that's what it kind of
builds up to in this rocky 4 is an
amazing guilty pleasure and I find the
ER was entertaining I hands-down I don't
call it the best rocky a lot of people
do love that movie legitimately so like
I understand there's like legitimately I
still think like the best rocky still
rocky well no I get that I mean but it
grows and it gets you know three is kind
of the in-between thing but it's still
more like one in 2003 is where the
cartoonish nough sit was introduced with
you know we though we talked about it
before with hulk hogan mr. t and all
that stuff definitely its present in
that movie but it's it flourishes in
rocky forth but yeah but we're talking
about going from that to this and
dragging it back down to like a real
human level i enjoyed that because like
i said i like the first two movies
that's why i'm a rocky fan in the first
place and it just did a great job at
like reintroducing i thought it did a
great job of reintroducing rocky to his
origins and stuff and you know
the reason for him being there that
losing the money thing was always just
like the most over-the-top explanation
about how Paul eat so this is what I
gather this is what happened Apollo now
Apollo Paul II was sent a contract from
the from Rocky's accountant to sign
about like extending his taxes so rocky
was in Russia and he decided because
Paulie didn't look at it he just like
gave it to him like signs we've gotta
mail it back so he gave the extension
under taxes when you get back as you're
in Russia for a few months so what it
was was a blanket power of attorney so
rocky was signing over power of attorney
to his accountant so he had complete
control of his estate so the accountant
invested all of Rocky's money into this
scheme for real estate and he thought
that he could flip the money and get all
Rocky's money back and make a super
fortune for himself before rocky
returned from Russia but the market
dried up and he lost all of his money
Wow complicated over drawn-out thing
like that scene with him in the yeah
yeah honestly and oh my lord a bizarre
way that felt somehow real to me I was
like this happened to somebody in
Hollywood
sure well that's all I kept I was like
this is so convoluted than specific I'm
like which one of these screenwriters
had this happened to a friend yes right
movie Oh an absent one all the Ponzi
schemes going around and probably Madoff
and like which by the way is my favorite
criminal name ever made already made
made off with all the money somehow like
I'm just like yeah that felt real does
it belong in a Rocky movie and it's just
so over complicated yeah that's why you
in the transcription video just trying
to condense it down I mean yeah hard to
believe that rocky would overspend he
didn't get paid for his fight with Drago
in 1985 and stuff well it's not that
hard to be money too much like the
Ghostbuster series you you have the
problem as kids or they have now gotten
kind of attached to this with a wave of
a series that go in cartoonish yeah I
remember being a kid like that whole
scene I was like I think adults are like
that who followed it
oh no not a lot of people did it was a
lot of legalese in there that just
didn't I mean I'm sure it made sense
when you thought about it really hard
boy I would get people to think about
the taxes you get I know when my yelling
at Paulie and those scenes is pretty
funny though just like very over-the-top
like I mean it's I mean she did well
Talia Shire did well with what she was
giving that scene but it's just like you
gave power power of attorney to the
accountant poly count yeah and it's just
man um but it's all understand we'll say
like all of those characters as much as
I love them in like the first so they
did get a little cartoon here with every
movie right I mean and they try even as
they tried to bring it back like there's
still moments in Rocky five like you
were just mentioning earlier where
they're going back and forth like you
know they're brother and sister and
having a you know big Italian family
fight I get it well I think I think part
of it too is like imagine you've been
doing these movies from the start like I
have and they're like what what
performant like what tone are we in now
like we just came out of the two
silliest and now you want us to I know
I'm serious about them I will say though
speaking of Talia Shire she has I think
this is her best performance overall I
mean later yeah later
she's really fantastic the scene in the
street when time he drives off and and
Rocky's kind of having like a little
like brain flashback thing I mean he
just snaps about what's been going on
with him and then she kind of snaps back
at him about what's been happening with
but it's so believable like I almost
tear up at that scene sometimes because
she's she's so believable in that scene
and I've just you know I've seen people
who are kind of at their wit's end but
they're trying to to get through to
somebody act like that I mean they're
kind of desperate because they're before
as I met you the line is so you losing
your Fisher but like I do like I like
your performance oh yeah it's it's it's
a sad case of not a great line attached
to a good performance sure but I do love
that scene that's fantastic and also we
got to talk about sage Stallone the late
eh - Linda passed away a few years ago
unfortunately it's a unique thing to
bring your kid as your own son in a
movie I mean like Stallone is Will Smith
also found right exactly
I won't like sage is not that bad
no no I mean some really weird stuff to
work with scene and some nothing okay
Wilson Wilson schizo hit miss but it's
like I've seen performances they were
fine but then you get something like
after after sure Cheryl this is no after
earthkam at no I don't remember I mean
it's been so long I don't remember
having problem with the kid yeah yeah
we've seen so many like bad child actors
know which I want which I will always
reiterate is not the kids fault
no like I look at what happens important
shake yeah I know I was bringing back
he's kind of pushing shop he's the
postage over that but that is casting
and the director yeah somebody could
have said no right they did no but yeah
we know it's gotta be a unique thing for
Stallone and for sage at that point
because I mean he brought his kid in to
play his his son but he's also not
directing that movie though they tend to
hate you dead right I'll pretend alright
but also a bassoon is this middle ground
now because stone didn't direct this
movie so like I wonder how that worked
on set when you have a real father-son
acting team and I know very
that's a weird situation where I don't
give celebrities to me only owe me their
art I don't really give a crap about
their personal no I but that is a weird
situation I'm like I would have loved to
have been a fly on the wall and know
what the real relationship was like and
how it would have affected positive name
like did they have a super good
relationship then do they have a bad
relationship I did that affect their
performance cuz it is such a rare thing
where it's like some of the rare cases
where somebody like wrote a book about
that like I'd be like I read that right
sure be very curious how that works I
was the same thing with you know after
Earth I'd be very yes right yeah but I
mean but their relationship in this
movie is the thing that I find most
interest interesting and that's kind of
what I wanted to expand upon a little
bit in the fan scription video I didn't
get to go off on his
much as I wanted to mean that video is
already over a half hour unfortunately
because it's I had to carry over stuff
for my home dare you be passionate I
know I know but their stuff was always
something that I liked about that movie
and their scenes felt very raw when when
he was kind of going after his dad for
not being there and you know spending
time with Tommy and like that stuff
worked I thought there's a lot in there
I'm like is this life imitating art art
right anything like I'm what I'm not
sure because as a movie star he would
have been out a lot yes that's like him
working through his Oh Mitch yeah you
know writers all that they put their own
you know spin on things and their own
experiences into he said they write and
Stallone wrote this so I mean there had
to be some truth to that in some form
but so removing that though I mean like
do you think his son ever went up to him
but one thing Inc that includes the kid
that we have to address is the age gap
that happens mm-hm because I think the
kids like nine years old in Rocky four
and he gets off the plane from Russia
and he's like five years older and no
this takes place five years after 1990
but like I mean it was film then but
it's portrayed as like right after
but it's 1990 was he was he in a time
loop for five years we're in Doctor Who
continuity okay I guess I mean that's a
cut the time line with Rocky was always
been messed up since the first first
since the second one because I
supposedly take place right after that
and then lice is like to me that's kind
of like a cinemasins thing where it's
kind of like it's a little more than a
cinema scene it's it's does it wreck the
story though no it doesn't wreck the
story but it is the most obvious and
this one out of any of the Rocky
I mean he's obviously he looks older his
sons you know a young teenager now
instead of a kid I mean that's kind of
the biggest difference to me but that's
one thing I wanted to put in the fan
scription video like we're gonna have a
time five year gap because he could lose
the money over five years if he's not
boxing if he doesn't you know he has
maybe an accountant who isn't all the
way on the up-and-up he's sort more of
us slowly losing and losing his money
than just automatically work out what
was that 86 85 85 yeah I I think they
were probably just banking on and I
always gonna remember how
that kid looks five years before worst I
mean we're still a point-like home video
had come into its own right but I still
think like nowadays like it's so easy
that easy to just binge watch things
yeah to me like if I were like if I were
a kid and had seen that on the big
screen and it was five years later and I
had only seen it like Rocky for once or
twice on home video since then I
probably wouldn't even noticed yeah I
get that I mean but that is one thing
that I see people always talk about is
that big jump he gets off the plane this
kids a different kid who's five years
older but I don't know I guess to me to
me it's always story first
no absolutely so and like so like you
know that's that some for cinemasins add
it to the counter and it's like ah ha ha
ha but it's not like it's not like a
huge story problem to me yeah I mean I
have bigger issues if like the story
it's and and there were issues yeah get
into that well yeah that's one thing I
definitely want to add in there was a
five-year gap because I mean it you can
explain away some of the continuity it
makes sense I'm fine with you writing
that I just but that's one of the things
I definitely want to add in there and
also you know having that gap we can
compare more to Rocky Balboa where he's
been retired for you know at least some
period of time it's been half a decade
since he's been in the ring and stuff
and you can incorporate some of that
comeback stuff into my story so that's
kind of another reason why I used it in
there but I thought you'd serve the
story pretty well we could use you know
that scene from Rocky Balboa where he's
in front of the Philadelphia Athletic
Commission trying to get a boxing
license again and incorporate more of
that stuff into there but you know
moving on from that though I can't say
we can't talk about Tommy Gunn okay so
got to talk about Tommy Morrison the
actor who portrayed him by the way if
you haven't seen this there's a
fantastic 3430 SP ESPN documentary that
came out like six months ago about Tommy
Morrison I think it's just called Tommy
and it goes back you know all the way
about his whole life talking about his
upbringing and and he had a really
troubled life and going through Rocky 5
and then his death just I think like
2013 or 2014 he just passed away so but
he was diagnosed with HIV like right
after the rocky 5 came out or something
like that he was a real heavyweight
champion in boxing he'd beaten you
Mormon for the I think the WBC
championship every weight championship
I think after performing that girl sure
hilarious but he was a real fighter and
stuff and that was kind of one I think
he was the first guy that Stallone
Brandon was a real fire who tried to be
tried to bring him in as an actor
because we saw with Antonio Tarver and
Rocky Balboa and then there's a bunch of
actors and Creed who are actual boxers
especially in Creed two with Victor
Drago is a leaving it work Rocky fives
Tommy Gunn no that's because that's what
I've been sitting here thinking about
that was like I never left
that's the biggest problem is that I
never felt invested in I get what they
were trying to do like I get that ties
into Rocky's kid about him being jealous
of Tommy and like Rocky trying to
vicariously live through this guy and
the Fallen pupil thing is interesting
it's an interesting story and it works
in a lot of other contexts but in Rocky
v when you have him I think maybe was
just too much it's like he lose long as
my knives back in the old neighborhood
yeah he takes on this this protege and
now he's been coaching his protege and
then he fights the protege at the end
and he also also has problems with his
son and like maybe it was just too
unfocused maybe that was one of the
issues and I know people don't like
Tommy's acting I don't think he's that
bad some of the writing he was given
like the lines he had deliver were
pretty awful when he's mad he's angry I
think that he does his best I mean it
might be like what I was complaining
with earlier where a that Seema baby
your family words like it might be a
decent performance but the writing
doesn't back it up so the dialogue is a
little child I will say as a kid I
remember and even watching it again back
in high school I just didn't think much
of his acting but no he's not he's not
like great he's not even like really
good there's some scenes when he's
really bad but I mean he does have some
enemies come off with like you know
Dolph Lundgren he didn't have to say
anything no you didn't have to say
anything but he did have a body presence
like that guy staring you down yeah for
sure does um you lose
but then you've also got like mr. t
you've got a Hulk Hogan you've got like
I think there's a difference I think
what what gave them is cartoony as they
were a bit of a bonus is they're
entertainers yeah like there was more to
the performance that when I shoot to cut
everyone and I'm not saying you had to
go complete cartoon right they were
trying to buy that up with what Apollo
Apollo Creed is another one we're like
actually don't look at all of the acting
had a quality bit out later he was
rounded out later but all of the acting
had something that you could kind of
chew on rise in rocky v is just like I
couldn't even remember I was think I was
like what's the villain in Rocky v until
I saw the machine gun now to be fair
like when I say I was a senior in high
school or something that's like 1998 so
that's 20 years ago so I'm like you cut
me some slack cuz I'm sure people come
it's how can you forget but yeah like I
it didn't leave much of an impression
huh no I mean I understand that I mean
the real guy who was over-the-top and
got the chew and all that stuff was Duke
George Washington Duke he was amazing
he's great I think I remember all the
times watching that movie he was the
thing that I love most about them I mean
he's more I mean she's not focused on as
the main villain it turns into Tommy
later but he that's why I tried to do
with the transcription video is he's the
villain like he's the and I loved that
changes when I watched the movie I get
like when I watched the movie in high
school I was just like I felt like he
should have been the villain yes like I
was like cuz rocky I thought just
couldn't he could box anybody like this
this Duke guy he should be like the
shadow puppet master villain Yeah right
she sort of is but that it is but the
movie doesn't make it about him like
screwy and it should've yeah absolutely
I think focusing on that more about him
just totally insulting rocky and you
know bring him out that way out of
retirement and Tommy being like his
surrogate almost like I still have Tommy
that have sort of a character he's just
very angry
kind of like a less fun clubber lighting
is what I kind of competitive but just
he's just upset that he isn't getting
the respect he deserved because he's the
youngest everybody champion for this
he's 20 years old he's a heavily
in the world that's a big deal but he's
still the right the rocky shadow is
still over like all of boxing because
boxing is like how it was in Rocky
Balboa where the division just sucks at
that point that's when I kind of wanted
to put into this so he does have a
vendetta against rocky still but I do
him to Billings both sides would he like
start sighs like he doesn't really care
about him we see him playing out sides
and he really only has his best his best
interests at heart not Tommy's so yeah I
think you know portraying him in more of
a villainous role which he was listen
rocky 5 but I mean more of the main
focus of being the main bad guy would
have helped the movie out a little bit
and also having the fight in the ring I
think would have would have helped out I
know that you know it could work
possibly having a rocky movie without a
fight in the ring at the end because
what I like and what most people like
about Rocky is not the boxing just part
of it it's not the main reasons the
chariot uh sure it's the frost but you
kind of need the frosting to make a kick
ya know what I mean so it could work but
I couldn't figure out a way to do it
without a fight in the ring at the end
and still don't kind of realize that -
that's why I went back to more
traditional formulaic tendencies with
Rocky Balboa you know leading up to that
big fight it is more of the progression
that Rocky fans are used to and you can
still add a bunch of new things in there
but you have to kind of keep that step
by step thing going you know the time to
have done it without an actual fight
would have been right at the beginning
with rocky - yeah you you had that one
small window where it's it's like okay
are we gonna change the formula or we
gonna do the same thing again again and
what happens is they got pigeon-holed
where they did this one two three four
times in a row yeah and and that's the
thing like the later ones
it's never gonna quite be Rocky one
which just felt kind of fresh and new at
the time it's like now we're in the
formula that's okay like it doesn't have
to be oh it doesn't have to be the
world's greatest art film now because we
are pigeon-holed into this and people
looking at it as like inspirational
stories alright I'm okay with it but the
thing is like
five was not the time to be like that's
it we're gonna switch everything it's
like you had your window and you missed
it yeah now everybody's used to this
like you can claim oh fours way too
cartoony so let's bring it back but he's
still got to adhere to some formula
that's what the people expect now
exactly yeah so I mean having that fight
in the ring at the end and like I said
before incorporating that sort of Rocky
Balboa tone of the big comeback kind of
I think would have been fantastic in
Rocky five if they would have taken that
angle I you know I think people would
have been into it more I don't yeah so I
mean yeah that's just part of it though
I mean I want to watch a movie multiple
times as I watch the other one right but
only twice only twice if it got any
better I will say you know I point out
some of the acting and this is really
strong with Talia Shire and even with
sage and Sylvester Stallone a couple of
those scenes but I think one of my
favorite rocky moments period if I were
to make a top five best rocky franchise
moments the flashback at Mickey's gym
yeah would be in that top five it would
be number one gap it would be in that
top five video if I were to make me
it's just perfect like how it looks like
how much shot is just gorgeous him
getting out of the Andes bar and seeing
Mickey's gym it's all dilapidated and
stuff when he goes inside and just it's
all gray and blue and like the colors
are great and then we get that flashback
I love the we have just the static shot
and then we just fade in I'm you know
when the ring was up kept and everything
and mm-hmm and he's training and make
fantastic lighting in there and burgess
Meredith what a fantastic idea I know
he's great and just to bring him back
for this movie was a great idea mmm it
just it sucks that it wasn't the movie
surrounding that that comeback sorta
with him wasn't better you know because
I think would have been the people would
have been talking about this more if the
movie was better because he's great in
that scene he's so good and it just
makes you like remember the the first
three movies in like ah he was like he
it was a really missing element from the
third from the end of the third and the
fourth movie yeah yeah I just love that
scene so much there's there's so much to
that and you know stone doesn't he's
just reacting he's just you know looking
without many
I think it just repeats a couple things
that Mickey says and there's no a
rocking sure but then there's just like
a single tear that comes at the end and
just that scene it is like pretty much
perfect if you were gonna take that
angle I'm rockin in terms of bringing
him back and everything I love it so
that's one thing and I draw from it that
I will not apologize for liking is that
scene it's just fantastic
but moving on from that you know I had
to bring in my Rakhi for changes into
this because this is a sequel to my
Rakhi for changes so a parlous
totalizing my version shares fear I had
to bring Apollo into this he's still
obviously in the wheelchair and
everything so that I had to incorporate
into the story and the title of the
video the thing that I think people
would be most interested in is if we
brought Adonis into this he would be
about four years old at this point I
loved that you tied it into Duke being a
douchebag yeah you you brought all of
those plot threads together by him
trying the out Apollo and you know
Donna's being his son you know right
he's trying to jar not just Rocky's
pride but Apollo's pride because if he
can't get to Rocky's gonna get to his
friends to get to Rocky exactly I was
brilliant it makes him more of an
interesting villain yeah for sure he's
just super slimy even slimmer than in
the original movie so but yeah the scene
where I have them meet you know I drew a
lot from the first scene from the first
Creed film where Marianne meets Apollo's
son Adonis and everything in our
introduction so it's kind of that
similar thing but he's a lot younger in
this version so he's a little bit more
innocent but still kind of this angry
kid and Apollo has to you know reconcile
with this mistake he made in the past
and I wanted to hammer home that he's
still paying for the mistakes he's made
before for his arrogance and everything
that happened before the rocky 4 fight
and that's just another mistake that
compounds on top of him being paralyzed
and he admits that that was his fault he
should not have taken that fight he took
it too lightly in the first place and
you didn't know anything about dragon
going into it so he's still paying for
his past mistakes and how he reconciled
with that and how he gets past it I
think would have made a really
interesting story well and it's a
counterbalance to rocky reckon so
his own relationship with his son
exactly you got these dueling you know
parallels father-son relationships with
two women also who are just like in the
thick of it just like sperm what do you
I would have had it you know I this
would have been a long movie I realized
that this would have been like probably
the length maybe Cretu is about two
hours ten minutes
I think that would have been about this
to fit everything that I wanted to fit
in there I mean cuz just me explaining
it's a half hour so it probably would
have been around you know why do hours
and people sat through nine hours of a
couple of short guys throwing a ring in
a volcano so I think you are you
comparing Stallone's amazing writing to
Tolkien and everything with lore the
Rings I'm not comparing Stallone as I'm
honored Toki I'm not comparing Rocky 5
but yeah I think rocky isn't it is an
exceptionally well-written film and I
have always defended Stallone as he's a
good right being under and he also a do
it the first first blood for the first
ramble yeah which is a great movie the
first Rambo movies over time because of
his mistakes I think there was a
backlash and I think it got to a point
where even now maybe I think he's kind
of underrated as a writer there was time
when like a lot of critics like this guy
like you gotta look out for this give
this guy and then you know he had a
bunch of Miss steps and stuff it was
Sally yeah people people forgot it was
pretty decent I know I I think when he's
when he's on he's really on I think he's
incredible right yeah he's been trying
to write this Edgar Allan Poe biopic for
years have you heard about that I know I
really am curious about - man - since
like since like rocky - era he's been
trying to get this man he posted like an
Instagram picture recently where he has
like the first draft and says like 1979
on it and now he has a new draft he's
still trying to get it made and he's
like 72 or 73 now 74 so swollen still
trying to get that movie made so I'm
curious as well because obviously I
don't think he'd be in the movie so I'd
be really curious to see what he like
what take on Poe he would like to show
everybody that he's been wanting to for
so many years now ends with a boxing
match with the world
yes I want to see that with me I think
it's making another Expendables movie
but I'm done with those the first one
was fun cuz it yeah like cool it's a
cool game I put they mean they're making
just for me their formula and I don't
there's an audience for it that's one of
those you know it's like I have a guilty
the Fast and Furious movies to me are a
guilty pleasure yeah
the formulaic movies I'm the audience
whereas I like RJ's is like it's like
I'm not gonna sit here and say it's high
art but right let the people see Fast
Five is the best one I think that's when
they brought in the rock good stuff it
was like right it's pretty good one it's
right in between the the superhero
elements basically in that in the 6 & 7
s them and like the more like street
races their first couple but yeah
besides yeah you know yeah fascinates
neither here nor there right exactly
I think if people went back and watched
Rocky 5 now I think that they wouldn't
totally hate it as much as they did when
they first saw it because number one it
didn't kill the franchise we got Rocky
Balboa which most people like and the
first two Creed movies and probably a
third one that people love so I honestly
what are you God knows I don't think
what Stallone did after rocky v helped
cement Rocky 5 as not as bad of a movie
because when I think back to some of the
things that start in Rocky 5 like it the
later films kind of gave rocky 5 a
little bit more meaning yeah because him
losing his money that you wouldn't be
able to see ya wear a boa I kind of I
kind of look at it's like you know it's
like that they little prequel you don't
need me but if you want to see kind of
how we got here yeah you know the worst
thing ever I think it's it's I'll have
to watch it again my guess is it
probably holds up maybe a little better
now it's never gonna be good no it's not
a good movie conventionally I mean but
there's a lot of potential in there and
I mean we're talking about before we
start rolling like that there's there's
elements to it that we discussed here
that if just work there what the right
way could have made are interesting
enough well Doug and I were just we were
talking about this 4 X 3 which was a
real sibling rivalry because he defends
that film and I yeah I know now that but
beast is cool yeah that's the only great
I I think we Rocky five falls into a
similar category at least for me hmm
Doug might disagree but there's ideas
that x3 brings up and certain there's
certain scenes like there's certain
scenes and extra they actually kind of
enjoy and on paper they look great
somehow assembled the way they're
assembled and with scenes that just kind
of sputter out and don't go anywhere and
with all these questions it brings up
but then it doesn't answer or truly
really resolved
the whole thing implodes yeah and I feel
like Rocky fives very similar it's like
I can see all that potential there and
like some great ideas but somehow in the
execution is just all imploded yeah it
fell apart I think it was a combination
of the story being written for Rocky to
die you know avildsen kind of clashing
with Stallone which has been a rumor I'm
percent sure if that was true or not
but just like the different tones that
he wanted to bring to it and what's the
lone one to do with it but he didn't
want to direct the movie I think it just
all those things combined and they're
adding Tommy Gunn and then you know
coming off of Rocky for all those things
mixing in just made was kind of an
athlete I almost had appetite for a
recipe for disaster
I have an appetite for disaster yes
after watching Rocky 5 so yeah it just
kind of didn't and even Stallone admits
he says all the time how much he didn't
think it worked but but it has its
merits and I think that if you guys want
went back and watched it and just
realized that it didn't kill the series
it you know it spawned Rocky Balboa
which a lot of people like we may have
gotten Creed but it wouldn't been the
same for sure
so take another look at it and see what
you think that account series like
saying well Batman and Robin well
literally now we've got like famines or
something afterwards which three which
two or three of which could be argued
are very good and then also crappy ones
that we can argue all over again
it killed series right but I mean you
know with with Batman there's always
gonna be another Batman movie I mean
what was was it eight years six years
ninety wouldn't Batman Robin come on 98
98 97 something like that but there's
nowhere a battement a battement Begins
came out in 2005 so there wasn't that
long the gap between rocky v rocky
Balboa's
sixteen years that so for a long time
people thought that was the end that's
that's a decade over a decade and a half
yes
so it really cuz nobody would touch it
though or because Stallone was just like
so disappointed we like she's alive you
try it was trying to make Rocky six or
Rocky Balboa since 2000 yeah he was
trying to make that movie for a long
time I think one of the best things he
did was ditched iva vet or the studio
whoever's decision was is to ditch the
goddamn numbers yeah I guess I'm not
sure well I like it I like just carry on
Rocky 10 bring uh bring me Rocky Tim I
don't like I'm not sure Rocky Balboa as
a title was a great title no I know and
the the more recent ones I thought have
been fine it is a great time free this
is a free nastic time yeah that's great
cuz Whoopie we could do that rocky 8 :
Creed yeah no just Creed you needed that
relaunch like I get it cuz it's a
spin-off film it's not a direct sequel
we're following a Newton main pair I'm
happy they ditched the number sure I
said that's fine I mean it was getting
very Star Trek II right Rocky 6 it's the
undiscovered country no you know I was
always doing like this after spider-man
3 cuz I was like you know Rocky Balboa
was good like Rutley redeemed the series
what I can't spider-man fix themselves
you know but they never did that and
they went off with amazing spider-man
rebooted two more times now actually
they did do it cuz spider-man homecoming
and now far from home that there's no
numbers attached to that no item a
wanted to but like I mean right now
Balboa like everyone likes Rocky Balboa
for the most part so it's like if you
could redeem the series like why not
like I wanted to spider-man for I wanted
them to fix it
wait what might do that for July I think
when far from home comes out I might do
a fireman no I've got it I'm doing
ghostbusters 2 yeah I ask you what's the
next one little Ghostbusters 2 a little
a little help from Doug we were kind of
brainstorming what we want to see he had
some good ideas sure going off of what
we already did it yeah you guys right
nostalgia critic review that so that
part of the video will be the same
because we think
open the same like we didn't that
nostalgia critic video yeah and I and I
still to this day like would be like
female reboot rekt this series of did
y'all sit there Ghostbusters to when I
was a kid I like that movie but I was
kids a bunch of you know hard-drinking
chain-smoking blue-collar Mouse's you
know if suddenly turned and do like
Peters playing with a baby
there's mood slime they're making a
toaster dance I'm like this is just the
and Duncan I both agree like
particularly like the slime it's just
like this this pink color yeah just look
like blood like what it's supposed to be
blunted first I thought so but it's yeah
they don't smoke they don't drink I
barely swear in the movie and I'm just
like they turn them like this kids
property so we wanted to make one that
was like like the first film like a
little more adult like kids can latch
onto it to but well kids would like it
anyway I mean yeah worse the worst thing
that ever happened to Ghostbusters was
kids liking it because that's when if
that's when the studio notes came in and
ever is like oh now that kids like it we
got it like soften it up and that's why
only the first movies really really
stood the test of time
certainly not ghostbusters to which I
get it a lot of people like it's a
guilty pleasure
I love Janos to yawn ocean Viggo need
their own sitcom but the movie as a
whole is that great and then the reboot
wasn't any good and now of course we're
gettin what do you think about that I
want to ask I mean cuz I think when that
trailer first came out everyone's like
oh this is ghostbusters 3 but now we
know it's following kids so it's gonna
be like stranger thing Oh what nice
quest oh my god when I heard like well I
can't tell what's what but one rumor I
heard it's kids this is gonna be like
frickin stranger things they asked a
couple of kids in it or I heard oh well
they're teenagers
I guess the furniture things kids are
actually kind of teenage I heard they're
trying to get the main the main kid from
stranger things to be in the movie
wolfbane or whatever the kids a Finn
wolf are yeah
Finn what a name Finn wolf heart Wow
yeah they're trying to get him to be in
the movie her I don't know if he's got
but
I don't know if that's confirmed or if
he's got a major role or no I've just
heard it's a rumor that they're trying
to get him in the movie to be the rumor
I heard is that they're gonna be
teenagers I'm like great so now it's
extreme Ghostbusters like what people
know was it the Real Ghostbusters no I
love the real I liked the Real
Ghostbusters I don't watch the hated
hated Slimer in the Real Ghostbusters
and then the extreme Ghostbusters I
didn't hate as much as Slimer prime is
like this is just so studio calculator
is I'm done I've checked out if it's
listen if it's great great I'll be like
in the movie I'll go to prison
we'll be happy be quiet you know if I'm
wrong we're wrong but I mean I put the
reins I did like thank you for smoking I
like some of the things I just but
that's the thing if there's a studio
attached and I still am looking at it
like and when they talk about having
kids in it I'm like it lightning struck
once and it's not gonna happen again
maybe again maybe I'm wrong I could be
100 percent wrong but so far lightning
is an Emma stork again because
everything that made that movie work is
gone they had the freedom and they had
the environment to do it they had a
gritty 1984 New York that was one thing
we can complain about how like cartoony
and awful the special effects are in the
reboot but the fact that you said it in
Times Square to begin with automatically
makes it rougher because New York is now
clean and - like Tokyo Disney or
something now it's you look at that
movie that was set in 1984 and it's like
new it's grimy that's everything that
made that movie working is just done and
I'm really like not enthused yeah I know
like we were gonna make it for the fans
I'm like you could have said that about
the second film - and that didn't work
like yeah I don't know man I mean I when
I first saw that trailer I thought I was
gonna be dose Buster's three just
without Harold Ramis
like it was gonna be ghostbusters 3 with
the original cast that's how they kind
of played it up and they didn't tell us
what it really was at first which they
knew what they were doing with that they
wanted to build hype for before they are
like and they I don't even read any
announcement about it about it being kid
and stuff we just kind of slipped in the
news
no and it's like of course if you say
anything about go so you'll get one of
two sides after you're the one that's
what if I say or if I say I didn't like
the Reeb it's like you hate Oh women but
I'm adamant I didn't I didn't like
either go or the reboot and I don't want
a third one right I just want it to be
done right
Ghostbusters it has this fandom that
split fandom basically yeah our wars
obviously has had that for a long time
and just been much more intense since
the sequels have come out yeah the
sequel trilogy so you know we don't got
there with rocky for the most part so
yeah hey man thanks rocky fans
except for Rocky five I guess but Shrek
we didn't have that pretty much
everything about that yeah sorry well I
think people were starting to get split
on the first abrams movie for star trek
so i remember people really being oh
yeah they are excited about that
yeah like reals avoid course Star Trek
fandom I don't know like the first day I
that's what we'll be doing eventually is
fixing the ending business I moved into
darkness and I actually like the third
Abrams right I was the next generation
fan so like I watched that growth next
gen III enjoy Oracle because more volume
it's like some comedic next gen knockoff
like where it's entertaining but yeah I
don't know these Lord of the Rings
fandom that's when I don't think they
argue that much or if they do it's about
like the elvish link right like major
series fandoms that don't like that for
the most part getting animal is each
other right power your fans don't argue
that much I don't think of this oh goody
for you and how are you I'm good for you
bailout here uh I wanted to ask your
final opinions final thoughts on rocky 5
anything else you want to say Rob I like
some of the ideas I thought it had
potential
I think it's since I haven't see I just
saw X 3 but since I'm insane I don't
know if I want to compare it entirely to
X 3 but I feel it's a similar thing
where I'm like yeah maybe I'm paper some
of these things look good but in the
wrong hands are executed in a certain
way it just it did not come together as
a role like sure I probably if I watch
it again I think X 3 is the worst film
but yeah I I love what you did with the
story and yeah there's some good acting
scenes in it and I love Duke right yeah
so but but yeah that was my initial
impression was it always just kind of
bored me and I Rocky as an adult the
first film does not bore me it is
deliberately paced but to me it's like
The Godfather or any other movie yeah
it's like if you're into it Godfather
comes on Rocky's very similar if rocky
comes on TV if Godfather comes on TV a
lot of movies like that all watching
beginning there that went crap now I
gotta watch it till it's over
yeah I am even though I'm sitting there
and like it's it's very deliberate like
it but it's like I love Miyazaki films
like a good anime like a lot of them are
very deliberate but I guess sucked into
it you know I love it solely yeah I'm
pretty much agree with you I mean just
some of the stuff I connect with in this
movie I just I just attached myself to
like some of the fighting with the
father-son stuff I mean everyone can
relate to that in some form just the
family stuff I really liked so and the
stuff with Ed makes Jim just like that
scene alone I like better than rocky 4
I'm sorry like I just that kind of
defines some of the rocky core essence
to me more than I think most
entertaining I will if you're gonna be
like oh I like it more than rocky 4 I'm
like I'm not objectively bad I'm not
gonna argue with you I'm ed just cuz I'm
like it sound like rocky 4 is higher
right so if you like this one better
because it took more risk so I'm like
going because I'm a risk it just felt
more like a rocky movie to me and I just
did like I said I attached myself to
some of them it is it totally does a
little bit more but let me know III
feels mocking Rocky Ford yes of course
but let me know what you guys thoughts
on it in the comments below
when's the last time you saw a rocky 5
have you seen it since Rocky Balboa and
Creed has come out the first accrete
movies what do you think of it compared
to that and what do you think of the fan
script for video what else do you want
to see us cover what other what-ifs
would you like us to you I know I know
at some point this will probably get a
lot of people pissed off but Doug wants
to do Mary Poppins yes that'll be fun
we'll hand that one over to Doug and let
him face the onslaught of Disney fans
yeah
wait for that one but probably in about
three weeks the end I guess that's the
end of this month we'll come out with
the Ghostbusters to fan scription video
so until then I'm Walter Bernays yak I'm
Rob Walker and we'll talk to you guys
next time thanks for watching or
listening both with your ears
[Music]
you